[Musica]
buonasera buonasera buonasera ho creato
mister e scompiglio bene allora io mi
scuso con tutti i tecnologici che ci
sono qua perché le mie slide sono queste
sono un po anzianità quindi sono un po
vecchio stampo con le slide poi mi perde
allora uso i fogliettini allora effetto
a catena ripoll effect
può il batter d'ali di una farfalla in
brasile provocare un tornado in texas
questo era il titolo di una conferenza
del 1979 di edward lawrence lo scopo di
questa conferenza era quello proprio di
dimostrare come piccoli effetti cioè
piccoli cambiamenti iniziali in un
sistema in un dato sistema potessero a
lunga scadenza a provocare grandissimi
cambiamenti
allora mi sono chiesta ma in questo caos
che viviamo oggi soprattutto per noi
donne quali sono stati piccoli
cambiamenti nel nel sistema all'inizio
che hanno poi provocato con questa
reazione a catena il delirio che stiamo
vivendo adesso allora mi sono andata un
po scartabellare i grandi pensatori
della storia dell'umanità
no che cosa dicevano delle donne allora
aristotele rispote le diceva la femmina
e femmina in virtù di una certa assenza
di qualità che se ci pensate un'area
proprio sapere il culo sui film lo dice
c'è e ci metti già quel secondo in più
che ti fa credere cavoli forse però ha
ragione no sono sono meno furba poi
arrivava il compagno di merende platone
che diceva ringrazio gli dei
perché prima mi hanno creato
libero e non schiavo il secondo perché
mi hanno creato uomo e non donna ma
ringrazia gli dei che non mi e mai
incontrata sull'app la strada perché
tirava una manata che ti chiamavano
piattone ti chiamavano poi sentite cosa
diceva questo prima vi dico cosa diceva
dopo vi dico come si chiamava diceva
esistono molti mostri sulla sulla terra
e nel mare ma il peggiore di tutti resta
sempre la donna alla donna una
sofferenza che non dà tregua
chi l'ha detto menandro ora se ti chiami
menandro ai problemi con le donne fatti
delle domande o più parolo
dell'antichità no ma veniamo ai nostri
giorni c'è più più recenti quantomeno
freud il padre della psicanalisi diceva
due cose fondamentali delle donne diceva
la prima che le donne hanno una
coscienza meno sviluppata e fin qua
tutti i torti non ce li aveva perché
visto poi con chi ci sposiamo
forse aveva anche ragione la seconda era
che noi donne abbiamo l'invidia del pene
e mi sono sempre chiesto ma perché una
deve invidiare uno che c'è un pene solo
quando volendo può avere tutti quelli
che vuole mi sembra veramente un idiozia
caro freud ma evidentemente ci dava un
po dentro comunque questo c'è giusto per
chiudere il ragionamento non me ne
vogliate a male però si chiama pene non
si chiama gioie un motivo ci sarà ora
c'è quando tu fai una cosa sbagliata
dice ma no ho fatto una cazzata
quando fai in europa bella dice ho mai
visto che ci sarà motivo allora allora
andiamo avanti perché a questo punto
torniamo a bomba no sull'effetto
farfalla teoria del caos reazione a
catena allora quindi ogni cosa è una
reazione allora quindi se un battito
d'ali può provocare un tornado in texas
può un messaggino non cancellato
provocare uno tsunami in casa può un
brutto voto dato a uno studente
provocare la rottura del setto nasale al
professore può una violenza su una donna
in pakistan far girare i [ __ ] a una
donna in italia può e come se stiamo un
attimino zitti proprio in silenzio
possiamo anche sentirli girare ma perché
questa è una cosa è un effetto a catena
importantissimo perché tutto quello che
capita le donne
scusate ve lo devo dire non è solo
affare delle donne riguarda tutti uomini
e donne è una cosa bruttissima che
capita una reazione a catena che si
ripercuote sulla vita di ognuno di noi
ogni giorno a livello mondiale e anche
non fare niente
ahimè è un'azione che provoca una
reazione a catena
ovviamente è sempre colpa delle donne no
questo da che mondo è mondo dal peccato
originale di stam e la noc e poi voglio
dire erano in due e sparita una mela che
ha fatto il report lui è stata lei
grazie al cazzo no scusate adesso di
ascoli così son capaci tutti però ancora
oggi si ripercuote cenò nei detti nelle
cose che dice donna donna al volante che
non è vero ragazzi noi spendevamo meno
adesso no perché hanno imparato tutto
con la crisi però spendevamo anche meno
per le assicurazioni perché facevamo
meno incidenti poi magari andavamo a 30
all'ora in autostrada perché nel
frattempo ci trovavamo facevamo la
maglia però voglio dire delle robe così
oppure che ne so donna nana per di anche
quella non è che ti viene in mente a lui
che magari lui che deficit on a train o
sei tu che a bucare sempre colpa delle
donne gli sul anno a lui la macchina
sotto casa è colpa tua
perché non gli hai ricordato che doveva
togliere le chiavi dal quadro e
chiuderla
la sua squadra del cuore perde colpa tua
non del portiere perché quando
l'avversario ha segnato eri vicina al
televisore portato sfiga
cioè se domani di piombo meteorite sul
piede colpa tua perché non è chiuso bene
la finestra e così via noè quante ne
leggiamo di ste notizie quante scuse ma
era lei che era vestita provocante ero
ubriaca era in giro di notte da sola e
quindi cosa fai abusi la giusta e poi la
reazione a catena io ho pensate che
nella mia vita ma quanti ragazzini ho
visto che giravano a petto nudo in
pantaloncini ubriachi di notte o non mi
ha mai sfiorato il pensiero chissà come
mai comunque meno male che a volte
capitano delle belle notizie sono delle
notizie che ti fanno tornare la fiducia
negli uomini finalmente pensate questa
ragazzetta poverina è stata stuprata a
scappare dal suo aggressore proprio
voglio dire immaginatevi le condizioni
sotto choc ferita trova uno per fortuna
la prende la porta di lì si apparta e la
disturba che s'era già pronta no è come
dire se già non è colpa di lui e verbali
lei un po come la torta della mamma la
domenica mattina sai che non devi mara
lei che era invitante
oppure che ne so una bambina e proprio
realizzato i sogni di ogni bimba c'è
quello di sposarsi a dividere con la sua
migliore amica perché l'ha sposata il
papa 11 anni questa bambina pensate che
bello
di giorno gioca con la sua migliore
amica la notte fa un po schifo è quello
che dico ma fa scritto quello che dico
io oppure fa schifo lui con la società
e quel sottile pensiero maschile che
ancora oggi non si ha il coraggio di
denunciare in india in india gli stupri
di gruppo sono all ordine del giorno
un ultimo articolo ti ho letto 17 in 17
hanno violentato una bambina di 11 anni
17 e al grido che si è levato ma come
mai 17 anno di un intanto la bambina è
perché gli altri tre si sono persi per
strada
abdul cia e le risate che continuano
attenzione 144 le vittime donne decedute
l'anno scorso dove dal suo mondo
no in italia e se parlo di decessi vuol
dire che le altre si ostinano a
sopravvivere no ce ne sono ancora magari
coma farmacologico così che insistono a
non morire
facciamo una piccola parentesi parliamo
del movimento mi tu non ti ha toccato in
tutto l'occidente ha scosso è la leader
di questo movimento colei che è ispirato
addirittura l'icona della donna con la
mano alzata asia argento
asia argento italian asia argento
all'anagrafe aria maria vittoria rosso
argento per gli amici peppa non duro si
chiama veramente così
ora asia argento a chi è simpatica si
argento argento con il padre che ha con
le possibilità professionali che ha
avuto di diventare quello che voleva ed
è riuscito a malapena a diventare quello
che voglio dire cioè sarebbe come dire
che il figlio di einstein insegna
matematica alle scuole elementari
asia argento se non si fosse capito non
è che mi sta particolarmente simpatica
come la maggior parte della gente non la
stimo particolarmente quello che fa o
dice non me ne frega una beata fava e lo
dico tranquille perché tanto se tu
chiedi asia argento guarda che debora
villa parla male di te le dice che
quindi io in questo caso sono la
minoranza dai famosi tutto il mondo
posso criticare non so che magari alcuni
maligni di cava non è che l'invidia che
parla ma certo il cazzo dell'invidia
voglio dire asia argento ma vogliamo
parlare che se suo padre facesse
panettiere le a quest'ora starebbe
sfornando 2 rosetto il francesino invece
fa l'attrice la regista la cantante la
scrittrice ed è bravissima a fare il
pane per dire c'è l'ironia della sorte
no asia argento che è bellissima e
bellissima asia argento bella è bella
come la notte non come il sole come la
notte con quella faccia da vampira un po
torbida con quel rossetto rosso
straordinaria bella che siccome lo metto
sembro joker temi si sfalda tutto che
non ci ho neanche le labbra
certo che l'invidia ma con tutto quello
che io posso dire o pensare di asia
argento
il movimento ha meno senso il movimento
ha senso è un senso pazzesca una portata
incredibile per due motivi la prima
perché anche nell'olimpo perché stiamo
parlando di hollywood capitano le stesse
cose che capitano
nei peggiori bar di caracas e la seconda
perché finalmente l'olimpo racz innata
finalmente le donne hanno avuto il
coraggio di denunciare
allora la prassi per vice fan era sempre
la stessa lo sappiamo la facciamo una
bella festa poi tutti andavano via e lui
rimaneva da solo con la preda e dico
preda perché se dico vittima fa già
colpevole invece preda sembra quasi che
a lei un po piacesse no il nostro usando
la parola sembra a caso perché se avete
visto by starbuck lui rimaneva con
l'accappatoio puoi fare quello che vuoi
dare sfogo a tutte le tue fantasie e ti
metti come nei peggiori soft porno anni
settanta cioè sei uno sfigato in se
penso uno sfigato no
certo le immagini vines che pensa di
essere fig in accappatoio no va bene
niente quelle arabe comunque attenzione
facciamo una piccola diciamo così un
piccolo excursus di quello che poteva
capitare durante quelle serate c'è una
festa deve parlare il produttore di un
filmino quando tutti vanno via
ci sta siete ubriachi
però è hollywood ci sta lui a un certo
punto prende va a farsi una doccia
questo non so se è vero l'ho aggiunto io
perché spero almeno che prima si lavasse
comunque ci sta e scene accappatoio dopo
la doccia ci sta e chiede di fargli un
massaggio è già qui non ci sta più
no voglio dire a questo punto però posso
farvi una domanda posso dire quanti
pensano che onestamente anche ste
ragazze ma potevano andare via un certo
punto mentre lui era in bagno mentre si
sdraia sul letto mentre farmaco c'è
prendi e vai via quanti pensano che
volendo potevano avere una scelta queste
ragazze potevano andarsene no potevano
scegliere di non dargli da quanti lo
pensano per favore dai sulle mani
chi lo pensa che grazie per essere
caduti nel mio tranne non è perché
attenzione trattasi di scelta
se nel caso a lille a dare o nel caso b
non gliela dai il film lo fa e lo stesso
se invece gliela dai il film lo fai
e se non gliela dà infine non lo fai più
non è una scelta è un ricatto giusto e
allora io a questo punto dico che non
può esistere una società una religione o
una legge che se crea una subordinazione
un ricatto o che ne so io una disparità
di genere o cittadini di serie a o b
abbia senso di esistere
ora
il movimento importante anche se
contiene mille contraddizioni questo lo
abbiamo visto questo lo dico da donna
c'è poi ci sono quelle sequel è nostro
ma non si è capito bene però la prima
vera bugia è che il movimento è nato in
realtà perché si voleva far cadere
weinstein tutto lì perché secondo me
sarà mica è stato l'unico a hollywood ad
avere quel metodo no persuasivo per
potersi fare quelle straordinarie donne
in tutto il mondo evidentemente ha
pisciato fuori dal vaso e qualcuno ha
deciso di farlo fuori e hanno utilizzato
questo questo questo metodo non importa
perché comunque le donne si sono unite
sono diventate più forti perché anche
nel gotha le donne hanno finalmente
dimostrato che unite possono far
crollare un sistema farlo a un sistema
fatto di soprusi hanno segnalato un bug
nel sistema il sistema stesso è
vacillato quindi ora agli occhi di tutte
le donne non sei più figo si abusi del
tuo potere per soggiogare il prossimo ma
sei uno sfigato il bullo è diventato uno
sfigato
e a questo punto dicendo no le donne
hanno continuato questo effetto a catena
iniziato in questo caso specifico da
rose mcgowan la prima a denunciare vice
neppure per quanto riguarda qua in
italia magari hanno dato vita a una
reazione a catena anche di un altro no
di questa franca viola che stata la
prima a dire no a un matrimonio
riparatore e non è da sempre che dicono
noi che lottano per i propri diritti
guardate che passi da gigante appena ci
lasciate tanto spazio cosi li
raggiungiamo in qualsiasi campo anche
addirittura dire siamo diventate
astronauti una cosa impensabile
solamente per proprio fino a pochi anni
fa ma soprattutto le donne dicono no e
lottano per dare un senso e un valore
alla vita ed è una cosa della quale
nessuno si accorge perché lo facciamo in
silenzio piano piano tutti i giorni
giorno dopo giorno attraverso piccoli
gesti
piccole cose ma per una carezza data un
bambino o anche una sgridata anche
semplicemente il fatto di prepararle la
cena per la famiglia e le donne sanno
che piano piano
riusciranno a cambiare il mondo e sapete
perchè lo sanno perché lo stanno già
cambiando attraverso proprio questi
piccoli gesti il rafale sono le donne e
con il loro battito d'ali stanno creando
un nuovo caos chiamato amore e se gli
uomini riusciranno ad abbracciare questo
caos
finalmente la vita avrà un significato e
sarà degna di essere chiamata così
[Applauso]